joining me today is an iraq
war veteran a political analyst and
america's favorite
black gay republican rob smith
welcome to the reuben report thanks for
having me dave america's favorite
black gay republican that's a lot of
pressure to put in a twitter bio
you know it's a lot of pressure i i feel
that um
about a year ago about this time because
i came out as conservative a year ago
and i i out as conservatives fascinating
phrase that we're gonna
talk about we'll get into that
absolutely but when i came out i said i
want something pithy
and catchy and kind of funny because
it's a joke yeah america's favorite
black gay republican i want there to be
a sense of humor in it
because as you know you know you use
humor to bring people in then you hit
them with the facts
so a lot of people are going to be going
wait a minute wait a minute these guys
are supposed to hate identity politics
but he's saying he's america's favorite
black guy a republican
well here's my thing with that i think
that there's
number one all politics is identity
politics so everybody does identity
politics the left does it and the right
does it
i think that since coming out as a
conservative the way i play identity
politics is this
i'm black i'm gay i'm a rockwell veteran
i'm all these different things
and they don't matter about my politics
because i can be all of these things and
still love america
yeah and the way the left plays identity
politics is
we hate you evil white men or you know
this is my 72 genders or all this stuff
so i feel like they use identity
politics
not only in a super negative and
controlling way but as a way to to get
people's votes
it sucks though to kind of have to do a
little bit of what they do to throw it
in their face right because like any
time
i don't mention that i'm gay that often
yeah but anytime that i do
i have no problem mentioning it like i'm
more than happy to talk about it yeah
but anytime that i do it really
only is to throw the use the way that
they use
gay people yeah uh it's to throw that
back in their face
like i have no i don't want special
credit for it you know yeah i mean
there's there's no special credit i
think that for me
when you get into my history and you
know i'm an iraq world veteran i
protested against don't ask don't tell
and i came out at 19 or i came out at 19
kind of like to
myself and a couple of friends of my
mother but when i got out of the
military at around 21 years old
because i had to serve under don't ask
hotel i said i'm done with closets
so i'm going to be out as gay so being
gay to me has always kind of been a
political act
yeah and when i was protesting against
solas hotel and getting arrested at the
white house and doing all these
different things
it was always a political act for me to
be gay so even
coming out as a conservative and being
on the right and i'm proudly on the
right
being gay is still a political act
because i have to go into these spaces
and say
i'm gay and this is why that matters and
this is how we can change
the party and change the idea of
conservatism
to bring more people in do you ever find
that conservatives
have problems with gay people because
people keep telling me that all these
conservatives hate gay people
and i go to events all over the place
all over the country all over the world
and i meet all these conservatives i'm
not saying there are none i have no
doubt
there's a certain sect of bible thumpers
obviously that still do
or some people that have different
religious beliefs you know ben shapiro
from an orthodox jewish perspective not
thrilled with gay marriage yeah but now
takes a libertarian approach civilian
which i'm okay with i don't need him
to bow to my beliefs but i don't find
that there's any
real pushback against gay people from
conservatives anymore i just don't see
it this is what i've seen
and and i've seen very very little in
the way of people having
some problem with me being gay the um in
my experience and i've been
god i spoke at the metropolitan
republican club in new york city and i
speak at these republican events all
over the country
and it's not so much i have a problem
with you being gay it's some people say
um one one person came up to me and she
said you know you're so good looking and
you're black and you know you're all
these things like
why do you have to talk about the gay
thing and i told her i was like i talk
about the gay thing
because it's very important for me to
talk about it because people need to
know there are gay conservatives out
there that follow me right now
that are afraid to come out and so i
need to take this gayness to this space
and let them know that it's okay
and also let you guys know that you're
missing out on a base of
millions of voters yeah by by doing
things that can even be construed as
anti
you think it's one of those things where
it's sort of you have to do it
so that it can get to the point that you
don't have to do it is that really
yes yeah and i was having the um this
conversation with with candace and i
shared this at the blex rally over the
weekend as well
um doing identity politics you do it now
so that at a certain point we don't have
to do it anymore so we have to say that
i'm a gay republican or i'm a black
republican or i'm a gay black
conservative or whatever you want to say
because as americans we have to break
all that stuff down
and and figure out what our identity as
americans
is and and that's the point for me yeah
all right so i want to talk about what
it's like
coming out as a conservative as a gay
black man
but let's just back up all together tell
me a little bit about growing up
family that kind of thing so i am from
akron ohio
one of the biggest um things that people
like to say to discredited black
conservatives
is that we were all born wealthy we were
all born upper upper middle class
and what we're doing is is we're just
trying to protect our privilege right
i'm from akron ohio so you weren't in
bel air
i was not in bel air all right i was in
akron ohio and check the stats on akron
ohio anybody that doesn't know where
that is
um went to the worst one of the worst
public school systems in the state you
can look on the website right now akron
public schools are rated d
plus so i came from a a single
you know mother household you know i
came from all this stuff
and my mother tells me the story now i
was too young to remember
but obviously i went to kindergarten
in a school that was in my neighborhood
and my mother tells me the story about
going to see me in kindergarten one day
and it was this you know it was a
99 black school she just people were
just running around crazy
and she said i had to pull you out of
that school because i knew you weren't
going to learn anything
wow sent me to school all the way across
town um
the school was was mostly white that
doesn't make it better or made it better
was the property taxes and it was just a
more
funded school so i was able to get
that kind of base went back to my side
of town
for middle school and high school which
was just a terrible experience
and i tell people all the time when they
asked me about you know sort of things
in in the world and western civilization
all that i'm like look i went to akron
public schools there are so many things
that i just do not know
um and so i had that experience but
in those days and probably still today
somebody that looks like me that comes
from where i come from
if i'm not dribbling a basketball or
doing whatever like they don't know what
to do with you
yeah so was not tracked into college i
wasn't tracked into any of these things
i graduated high school
at barely i think it was either 16 or
barely 17
and just had no path so i joined the
military right out of high school
because
i i needed a path i needed a job i
needed something to do
i wish that i could say and and my
military service is great and i love
this country
and that five years that i spend the
military is probably the the greatest
thing i'll ever do
but i can't lie and say that at 17 years
old like i was so patriotic i wanted to
serve my country like that
it was a way for me to move beyond yeah
yeah
all right well before we get to that i
can't let anyone mention basketball
i got a boy you got any skills no i
don't i'm the worst
black man ever i like am terrible at
basketball
i don't want to brag but i won most
improved player of the new york city gay
men's basketball
did you i think 2012 when i was already
like 37 which is
the most improved player at 37. yeah
that's not bad that's pretty good it's
really funny that um they have that gay
basketball lead there there's a part of
me
that has always wanted to try but i know
it'd be so bad
and dude they're a guy's dunking i mean
it's a serious it's a seriously and it's
funny because i don't
i always for me at least and i wonder
for you like my
sports and my sexuality had nothing to
do with each other
yeah ever like i never brought my
sexuality when i'm out on the court
in any way you know what i mean like it
wasn't like that the only reason i
joined that league was at that
point in my life when i did i came out
late and i finally was like ah let me
just meet some
i didn't really like like the the bar
scene or
like there's nothing there yeah like i
didn't i didn't like that and i was like
oh maybe
if there's happen to be some gay people
that also like basketball maybe
yeah you know i'll find some friends and
i did find some friends there and it's
like and half of them it's like you're
gay really
like and when a guy like dunks on you
and you yeah that's crazy
like some of those guys like almost went
pro yeah that's how good they are
the weird thing about kind of like being
gay and not only am i gay house we used
to be a fat kid yeah
um as well so you're really going for it
i'm like got everything did you have a
limp at any point
i didn't have a limp no i did not have a
limb but it was like fat like this was
like some fat black gay kid
was not athletic at all so i didn't
discover because there are some sports
i'm good at i played
in the gay volleyball league in new york
city for a couple of years and now i'm a
pariah since i came out as conservative
oh jeez yeah yeah but i thought they're
i thought they were all talented yeah
what do you think new york city gays
they're not very tolerant of
this not so much i am shocked but i
discovered that i
am athletic and i discovered that i'm
great at volleyball great at tennis you
know like
like lifting weights like being in shape
but that's kind of what i discovered
about myself kind of like i don't want
to say later in life but definitely post
30.
yeah that i actually you know have some
sports skills yeah all right good so
when you
joined the military were you already
sort of out to yourself
now i'm talking about sexuality not
politics no guys
but certainly not a conservative thing i
was i was out to myself i think
in the way that a lot of gay teens are
you know i knew that i was kind of like
feeling
a way about guys that i was supposed to
feel about girls
but i don't know if i could really kind
of quantify it in that way
and when i went into the military they
actually in those days actually asked
you are you gay and i said no
not only because i didn't know how to
define it at the time but also i knew
that that was a barrier to to what i
wanted to do
you know so being in the military i
came out to myself you know started
exploring my sexuality exploring all of
that stuff and like i said when i got
done with the military coming out was
like a political act i was like no more
closets yeah
were you finding other gay people in the
military
like what is that what was that like
then i mean now now where it's more
accepted and donated hotel doesn't exist
yeah and whatever the thing about um
it's really funny how it is now is that
there are entire instagram accounts
dedicated to gay guys in the military
it's called gay military dudes and i
love the fact that
these these young gay men in the
military so open
about you know their sexuality and
they're posting thought pics and they're
doing all this
like great yeah well and you're saying
the military hasn't crumbled since
and it's not causing uh demoralization
or everyone's still okay we still
everybody's still good okay but back
then
there was this this underground movement
of of gay people gays and lesbians that
were in the military and i remember
the very first pride i went to i was um
i was stationed in fort carson colorado
so like right in colorado springs
and my very first pride was denver pride
so i went there i think it was like
maybe 19 or 20 at the time
and that was my first time being around
a lot of other gay men
at the same time and it was the first
time that um you know i was i was
getting
attention from men and then like people
were looking at me and i was like oh
he's cute and i was like oh so this is
what this is like
um so there was a thriving underground
gay culture in the military how did were
you afraid to go
out and go to a gay pride parade while
you're serving
yeah absolutely because it's like if
don't ask until
was tricky because it was not only you
can't tell somebody that you're gay but
if you were
discovered to be gay then people would
um you know go
up the chain of command and kick you out
but the thing about it is and this is
what we always realized that nobody
would care
because there were plenty of guys in my
unit that that knew i was gay and
a funny story there was a club called i
think it's now defunct called hide and
seek
in colorado springs and they used to be
open to people under 21
after 2 a.m so i would be yeah yeah
what yeah yeah it would be open to 21.
uh it would be open to people under 21
after 2 a.m because it'd be like open
till 5 and um they wouldn't be serving
any booze
so i was young in the military as like
maybe 20 years old i would take a nap
at 10 30 and then i would wake up at 1
30 i would put on i had like
like leather pants and a tank top jeez
insane
crazy um and then drive to hide and seek
and dance all night
and it was kind of it was a more gay
crowd but it was mixed as well
and i saw a couple of my sergeants there
wow one time at the club
and they saw you and they saw me and and
they
saw me and they were like okay this is
interesting and they saw me kind of like
dancing with some redhead and
you know feeling my oats yeah you know
what i mean
feeling myself but i remember being
terrified that weekend that they were
gonna out me
that they were gonna like tell my
superiors or whatever it never did well
but you had it on them too
right i mean no they weren't gay they
were they were just like they were their
girlfriends because it was like
wow i just had a completely different
story going on in my head for the last
30 seconds yeah no they were there with
their girlfriends
yeah it was an after-hour spot oh oh oh
yeah
i gotcha yeah i thought okay okay and so
they did they didn't bust me out
and a lot of these guys are are still my
my friends to this day my facebook
friends and they see all the stuff that
they're doing i'm here on there and
coming out as a republican i'm doing all
this and they're like smith you know we
always knew you were gay
you just didn't care yeah you're a good
soldier so i know what most gay people
feel about being in the closet just how
you can be as a person it's just you
know
you're i always felt like i was like
lying all the time accidentally like
it wasn't even intentionalized people
would ask me something
and i could immediately you know where
were you last night and i could just lie
without
thinking you know it's really it's a
really twisted dark it's not fun to
think back on that kind of thing
um but for someone in the military yeah
don't ask don't tell
yeah do you think that affected your
ability
to function as a as a soldier and i
think it did
because the i think that to me
the biggest thing about being closeted
in the military
was that it affected the relationships
that i was able to have with my fellow
soldiers
there was a wall there and if i was able
to just be gay and
nobody cared that wall wouldn't be there
and and it's so important when you're
serving with people
to be able to be close to them like
literally to be able to to bring your
full
self to work because not only were we
serving together i mean we deployed
together you know i did a tour in kuwait
i did a tour in iraq these are the
people that you're with these are
basically your family and you have to
hide a part of yourself
and all the times that they were hanging
out or doing things that we could become
closer
i was separating myself from that
because i knew that there was a part of
me that had to hide
and so when i bring all of that stuff
now to to being gay and being open as a
conservative and everything
it is so important for me to be open in
that way because there i can't have that
wall there
between me and other conservatives and
me and other people in the movement
and the younger conservatives have been
like these kids don't
care yeah they don't care some of the
older ones need to kind of be brought
around a little bit but man they don't
care yeah do you think it's just because
young people
somehow have started to embrace a more
libertarian view of the world i mean
it's like we've got sort of
you know crazy leftism on one hand which
seems to be catching fire all the time
he's really pushed on us by the media
yeah but then i see and
i guess it's a little selected by by who
invites me to these schools yeah but i
see
such a strong libertarian
like spirit with these kids not meaning
that they're all politically
libertarians at every level but like
they just they want to live their lives
they want to love who they love they
want to
smoke whatever they want to smoke yeah
yeah or whatever and i'm very enthused
by that
i think that the the generation right
now they really do
just they just want to let people live
yeah and they want to let people do
their thing
they don't care about gay they don't
care about transgender they don't care
about any of these different things
they just want to let people live and
it's really funny like the conversation
i had last night
at ucla i had an event and it's so funny
because when i was protesting against an
[ __ ] tell i was i was you know doing
a lot of lecture work and i was talking
with
the young lgbt student groups and i was
just like you know you can be anything
you want to be
let's empower you like let's do all this
stuff and i'm having these same
conversations with young people who are
afraid to come out as conservative
same thing david yeah no it is all right
so all right let's just dive into it
yeah
because i really do feel this now
because i
i know what the closeted thing was like
as a as
in terms of sexuality yeah but i see
this now the amount of emails that i get
and when i meet people on the street
and they'll kind of whisper to me you
know it's not even they're not even
saying
yeah well they'll go you dave and then
they'll go it's not even that they're
saying they're a conservative person
they're basically just saying they're
not a progressive yes that they're not
they don't come from the woke monster
yeah you know what i mean and i and
they're walking around with that that
feeling that you described a moment ago
related to sexuality where you can't
be fully there with someone and i think
there are
there are quite literally i think there
are millions of people in the united
states
that are walking around in a closeted
state
not because they're nazis or white
supremacists or haters or racists
but just because they happen to have
either some conservative beliefs or
some libertarian beliefs or something
like that and i see it all the time and
i'm sure
you probably get 10 times as many
messages as i do but
you see it and when you go have these
conversations
it is the same conversations that i was
having with
young gay kids that were afraid to come
out i had a conversation with a kid last
night he was just like man
how do i come out to my friends as
conservative or how do i come out to my
friends as somebody who's like not a
leftist
and this is what i always say to them
you know the real ones will stick around
the fake ones will go i i promise you
that
and when like a year ago i remember
sitting i was visiting my best friend in
vegas
and i was thinking about i know from my
experience
you know being very prominent in in the
don't ask hotel thing
that when you come out as something like
you're coming out to make a statement
and it has to be a media moment and you
have to get your face out there because
that's what gives
other people the strength that comes out
and i was like man if i don't do this
somebody else is going to do this
because i know i'm not the only black
gay republican out there
i i have fans that are that are black
gay republicans yeah and and latina
lesbian conservatives and
and all sorts of stuff um but i was like
if i don't do this somebody else is
gonna do this
and somebody needs to do this because
these people need to know that it's okay
and when i take the hits and you take
the hits
and candace takes the hits and all these
other people takes the hits
it makes it easier for these other
people to come out so i've asked a lot
of my guests that have taken those hits
yeah this
question i usually ask it at the end but
what do you think it is about you
that allows you to to want to take the
hits
or maybe not even want to that you do
whether you want to or not
i'm telling you the army builds
something that is indestructible
indestructible i i served for five years
i saw some things in iraq i saw some
things overseas
and and not even outside of that
what the basic training does is it just
builds you up into somebody that has a
lot of discipline
that can take a lot of hits and i know
enough about media and i know enough
about
the people that are are making the moves
right now i know that it is important
for me to do this
because and i'm telling you dave and
you've probably seen the shift
in the past five to seven years since
you've been doing this and have really
been blown up and traveling all
the world there's a shift that's going
on yeah
and i believe it's real and in
three to five years me being a black gay
conservative
it's just gonna be like you know
whatever and i
hate the fact that the gay community i'm
kind of like i'm
excommunicated now you know so i'm not
getting um invites to the glam meeting
with me either yeah we should start our
own awards we totally should
the the the gay free thinkers awards you
know
but you get excommunicated and they're
they're
very high-level people that i mean i
used to get invited to
all the stuff in new york city because i
was a gay person in the media
and when i came out last year it was
like it was like silence
so what does that really tell you about
these organizations and sort of like
glad and these other organizations
they're four gay people right they're
supposed to be four gay people and and
if they
subscribe to intersectionality they
should be for black people and the rest
of it
but you're saying you were in that they
loved you yeah you come out as
conservative
we're done with you what it tells me is
number one that these organizations are
not for all
lgbtq people they're for lgbtq
um democrats yeah first of all these are
leftist organizations
people really need to understand this i
know i say it all the time but like i
think that because people
just think glad is for gay people yeah
this is for this part and it's like no
that's not really what's going on here
but it really takes work to get people
to fully understand why that
is true and there used to be and we
talked about this a little bit before we
started before we started filming
there used to be a part of me that
wanted nothing more
than to be kind of like a gay celebrity
like oh
i get to go i get to go to the glad
media awards and i get to go to the hrc
red carpets and i get to be and now
i realize that what i'm doing right now
is so much bigger than any of that stuff
and
i'm not i'm doing this not for fame or
because the concept of fame has been
very strange to me and grappling with
with this newfound attention but it's
not about
being with some d-less um gay
celebrities on the right carpet
it's certainly not about being with even
though i by the way usually the ones
that they're putting on the red carpet
they're not even gay half the time
oh yeah i told you i used to do these
red carpets when i had a show on aoq and
i was so i was interviewing people i was
on the other side of the red carpet
and mostly it was just housewives of new
york drunk
these drunk plastic women that are like
oh i love gays
let me tell you something and i can tell
you a story and she will remain nameless
yeah
but i was actually at huh you'll tell me
after it oh i can tell you the name
after yeah yeah
but i was at one of these award shows
and then this was obviously before i
came out when i was still getting
invited
and this person was just a drunken
sloppy mess and i'm just like how is
this celebrating gay people
how is this elevating us and so what you
have
is with the glads of the world this is
about bullying hollywood celebrities in
the thinking that you know what
if you don't if you don't show up to our
red carpet events you're not supporting
you know the the lgbtq community so
that's what
what that's all about um the hrc is
obviously a
leftist organization like very much so i
left this organization
and what irritates me about this entire
thing is that
these organizations were not started as
leftist organizations they weren't
supposed to be left as well because at
that time they wanted
real equality they wanted equality under
the law they wanted
the things that we have right now but to
continue to get funding to continue to
be data centers for the democratic party
they have to go with whatever far-left
craziness and it's the intersectionality
cold
and it's it's being lectured by a queer
muslim
at the glad media words about how gays
aren't inclusive enough for
islam and and about you know how how the
lgbt community
needs to accept undocumented people it's
just like all this
stuff that was never it's never what our
movement was about
and at the same time for me as a gay man
i know that
um hiv aids rates among young black gay
men are still exploding um we have a
huge problem with meth like there's real
stuff still going on
so what should they have done then was
there a moment that there should have
been a course correction so say gay
marriage gets passed don't ask don't
tell is gone yeah
what do you think the organizations if
they had done it right i mean is it is
it do they close up
shop do they well that's what i think
that's what they were afraid of they
were afraid of now that that we have
this quote-unquote true equality that
the close-up shop
chris chris rock i mean on his great
lines the cops need a certain amount of
crime yeah
yeah and i think that what happened
after
don't ask hotel repeal and marriage
equality were two of the biggest
gay rights wins of our generation like i
think of our lifetime and after that
happened i think that they just needed
something else they needed some more
funding they needed to
to continue to be relevant so they've
gone
into all of this intersectionality
far-left insanity
and what i see from being so open and
being
a gay conservative out here is that
there is
a large group of gays and lesbians that
are conservative that want
nothing to do with the leftist nonsense
they don't want to vote with their
sexual orientation they want to vote for
their values they want to vote for the
with their pocket books you know they
they
they want to vote based on who they are
so you're saying
let me get this straight yeah gay people
are just like everybody else just like
everybody else they
just like everybody else is crazy right
nuts
insane yeah and you'd think so where
where are the the right gay
organizations are are there any i mean
like the
cabinet republicans are there anybody
that you're out there and you're like oh
you guys are doing
some good grassroots work related to eye
issues
it's always it's never going to be the
hrc's and the glads of the world it's
always the grassroots organizations
it's your your your um columbus
pride you know it's your the brooklyn
community pride center
it's like these are the organizations
that our money really needs to go to
because these organizations are doing
work on the ground
to like give young lgbt people access to
jobs and education and all the stuff
that the glads and the hrc's of the
world claim that they're fighting for
but really they're just paying a lot of
big wigs sick
like insane six-figure salaries and and
trying to get madonna on a red carpet
and god love madonna we all love madonna
but that's not the word yeah so i always
try to elevate
the smaller organizations because they
need
the time and the money more than the big
ones for the record i'm more of a tina
turner guy you're more of a tina turner
yeah i hear she gives an amazing show i
haven't been yet i've never seen well i
don't think she's going live anymore i
think she's done touring
is she done i think she's like she moved
to like sweden or something i think she
gave up her u.s citizenship and she's
just
riding it out man yeah but um i what i
will say about madonna the gays are
going to kill me
i saw her one time and it wasn't great i
saw her once new york uh
confessions confessions on the dance
floor it wasn't it was in dna ah
oh that's the one that's yeah that was
the whole dance album right
no confessions was the dance okay so
mdna was like in in 2012 i think i was
on
mdma when i went to where you went
that's what it was okay i paid a lot of
money for those tickets we were at
madison square garden somewhere out in
jerusalem
yeah i was way up there in the rafters
and i was just like yeah
yeah i wait till i wait till the the
farewell vegas tour where she finally
does all the things that people want to
hear right
well age-wise she's she's getting there
yeah but you know she keeps it together
she keeps it together she does she does
all right let's uh
let's talk a little bit about i've heard
candace talk about how most
black people actually are conservatives
but they sort of don't know it or they
can't accept it because
of the way the media has treated black
people that the default position
is you must be a democrat yeah do you
sense that um i sense that
and to get into that you really have to
understand
how deeply entrenched this idea that
black people have to be democrats is
and and i said this a little bit uh on
the vice thing that i did
we have black celebrities
entertainers ball players athletes
from the top of the charts to the insta
thought
with 10 000 followers these are all
people that are pushing leftists you
know they're pushing leftist tactics
and black people we more so than i think
other races we look for representation
in media
and we look for representation in pop
culture and these are our heroes these
are
the people that we want to be like and
that's one of the reasons why
this idea that we have to be on the left
is so firmly entrenched
so why do you think that is looking for
it sort of elsewhere
do you think that has something to do
with the black family or some of the
stuff that larry elder would talk about
it has
everything to do with what larry elder
is talking about larry elder will tell
you and i'm pretty sure he did
that the number one kick the [ __ ] out of
me yeah that's what woke me up
yeah yeah but larry elder will tell you
that the number one problem
in the the black community is is black
popping listeners right
that we don't have men in the homes and
so when there's not a man in the home
when there's not a man
to to raise that young man in the home
they look to athletes
ball players the the colin kaepernicks
whoever and so
when colin kaepernick just to give an
example is some kid's hero right
and he sees colin kaepernick taking a
knee for black lives matter
and that's where he's getting his
politics from because that kid doesn't
know who i
am that kid certainly doesn't know who
larry elder is and the fact that that
kid is not going to know who larry elder
is is a shame
you know what i mean and so that's the
message that we get
even though black people do tend to be a
little bit more conservative
just in terms of if you
for example said that black people need
fathers in the home
and we need to stop having kids out of
wedlock and we need to start doing all
of these things that will elevate
ourselves you're a racist
i would say i would say everyone
regardless of race right should have
those things
to the best of their ability not to say
it can't happen otherwise you just said
you
you were raised by your mother i won you
turned out pretty good
of course there were those outlier cases
yeah but at the same time
i was i went to the military for five
years and so the military
taught me the military gave me a male
influence multiple male influences
the military taught me how to be a man
the military taught me discipline the
military taught me courage the military
taught me self-control the military
taught me reliance
all of the things that a father
is supposed to teach you and so now me
as a as a gay black man saying these
things
you know if you're a white person you
know you're a white supremacist or
whatever but i'm sorry about that you
know yeah
i'm the [ __ ] i'm the uncle tom i'm
whatever
and there is this very huge
movement of like very far left gay black
men
who it seems like they have these large
online platforms
and it seems like their entire goal in
life is to just
tear down straight black men or tear
down the idea of masculinity
or tear down the idea that our boys need
men in the homes to teach them how to be
men so they want to tear that down
and when i look at their platforms and i
look at the things that they say
and sometimes they come after me and i
ignore it because none of those people
are my enemy
there's nobody that is out there that's
a public figure that looks like me that
is not my enemy that is my enemy
these people are not my enemy but when i
look
at the platform that they have i say
you have so many people listening to you
why are you always preaching
divisiveness and hatred why are you
trying to tear down black men we should
be
lifting each other up we should be
empowering each other because you know
our
community needs it yeah well it seems to
me that mostly and it's not just
with say those black men but anyone that
buys in
to the far left ideology they want
conformity
yeah there is some sort of as i say all
the time peter bogosian who's been on
the show many times
calls this post-modern ideology a
secular religion
and they don't want apostates and they
especially don't want apostates that
look like you that's crazy i've never
i've never really heard that i mean i've
talked about that idea
in some of my lectures but i've never
heard it say quite like that because
this is my thing and one of the
best things that happened for me over
the past year is that i found religion
and i found god because i will tell you
and you probably know
they're and i don't know i don't know
what your religion is yeah
but for me there's a lot of people that
are running after
twitter followers and fans and instagram
followers and fame and money and all
this other stuff
and not there's not an amount of twitter
followers or frame or any of that stuff
that is going to fill
that hole that you're looking to fill
and
twitter followers don't fill the
existential
when things started taking off a little
bit last year
like when when my life started getting
bigger
and in some other ways i had to make
things smaller
um and so i made my circle smaller and i
tried to get closer with my husband or
my best friends but i also found god
and it is were you not religious before
or were you not were you were you
specifically not a believer before
no not not at all i was raised in the
church african methodist episcopal yeah
um so the ame church like i was there
and when you're young and black in the
church
church is a full like an all-day event
i'm there at 10 a.m for sunday school
and then you do the service and then
it's 2 30 dinner you're like you're not
out of there until after dark
but i think that in my first 11 years in
the city when i was kind of doing some
of the donational activism and trying to
find my path
i was looking for fulfillment in all of
those things that i told you before
and when i started getting those things
i realized that not that it wasn't
enough but there needs to be something
else to ground me
and one of the biggest things that the
the super
far left tells young gay people is that
god is your enemy and christians are
your enemy and evangelical christians
want to put you in conversion camp and
just
all of this crazy stuff to separate them
from religion so that this far left
ideology becomes their religion and
i i say that you know god is a gift of
my life right now and i say that and
i'm not embarrassed by that anymore and
i don't feel like that's something that
i should be ashamed to talk about even
as
a gay man somebody described me on on
twitter when i think it's funny
and they said um former military leftist
turn right wing bible thumping
trump [ __ ] and i thought that's a lot of
words
hysterical yeah i showed that to my
husband we both tackled
i don't hear you bible thumping no i
mean i'm not
you may be a trump [ __ ] and uh you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah right-wing
trump-tard
i don't bible thump i just i talk that i
talk about
religion in my life and how it's
grounded me and how it's become just a
really
powerful guiding force yeah and it it is
fulfilling
and it is grounding in a way that let me
tell you something as a young gay man
like
like all the sex all the partying all
that stuff like i did it all
and there's there's nothing in that and
for me
it is is becoming grounded in religion
and god yeah do you think a lot of gay
people have like an extra struggle
when it comes to sort of the existential
questions because i know i definitely
did like that
you you are something that society tells
you at least
you know how old are you huh how old are
you am i allowed to ask how old you are
i just get to the one question that i
can't say one question
i'm in my 30s you're in your 30s wow wow
yeah
yeah all right so that's how it is well
i as an elder i am 42 years old okay
so you know when i was in say high
school and college you know this way
before gay marriage yeah
you know during don't ask don't tell and
i i never really saw
sort of a functional future it's not
that i saw a dysfunctional future i just
don't know future i was just like i'm
now and i'm just gonna
keep living now yeah something like that
yeah um but i do think for a lot of gay
people it causes like this weird
uh belief schism yeah or something like
that so it's interesting to hear that
just in the last year
yeah you've come back to some of this
stuff and i think a lot of people have
by the way
i think they are and and i want them to
and it's like
so we we tell the i guess i don't want
to say right wingers anymore because i
guess i'm a right-winger now
but they always say that you know you
can't call gay a lifestyle because it's
my sexual orientation it's our lifestyle
but
there are elements of it that are very
lifestyle oriented
the the party lifestyle the circuit
party culture the gay culture like all
of that other stuff
um i don't like any of that stuff yeah i
like the golden girls
i who doesn't like the golden yes that's
like gay enough for me you know what i
mean i watch three hours of golden girls
on a sunday morning i'm very happy but
the cool thing right now
is that people like you and people like
me can
reach these young people and they can
see
something that is outside of all of that
messiness
and i come to it as not somebody that
judges it but it's somebody that
did it all now i never did drugs i was
never i was never a druggie i don't even
like smoking weed they say that
people that are um that are a little
neurotic
and i'm a little neurotic they say weed
doesn't go well with us and it doesn't
go well with me yeah so i never did the
drugs
you haven't found the right indigo but i
get it you're a conservative now it's
too late yeah yeah
no it's not even that because and it's
really funny i'm like to the right of
some people on marijuana legalization
but that's a whole other issue
we can go there but yeah good but i did
all the partying i did all the circuit
parties and i traveled and kissing boys
and having lots of senses like i did all
that
and i fundamentally know that there's
nothing there
and i think that the problem with
reaching these kids right now
is that i am like it feels lonely
because it really does feel like i'm one
of maybe three or four people that like
have these
large platforms and obviously you as
well but
they see people that are like you know
they see the drag queens and the
hollywood celebrities and all that other
stuff
i just really want these kids to see
that they can have a more grounded life
and not that i'm trying to be
anybody's role model in a way because
i'm like my
thing is i did all the mess so you don't
have to yeah i i feel very even though i
didn't do the ma i mean i did do my own
mess in a way
like and i did i did do the drugs and i
did do all that but i wasn't really into
the scene let's say
but i do feel that too i'm not trying to
be anyone's role model at
all a hundred years for failure yeah and
i
i live through if anything i would say i
live through
[ __ ] to get to where i am so that
hopefully
the next that that gay kid that's 18
doesn't have to
do it you know yeah or right because
everyone's got [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah right and the people that
came before me lived through far more
than that so
yeah but there's an interesting parallel
here with the way hollywood treats all
of this because you mentioned something
about
just a moment ago you mentioned how uh
that black
culture puts more emphasis on hollywood
and these
figures and everything and i was
thinking like even just in the oscars
last year that black panther
yeah was nominated for an oscar now i've
seen every
so so i think we're going to have a
little difference here because i i've
seen every marvel movie i just saw end
game a couple days ago yeah
uh that's what's going to make me go see
that this weekend yeah i don't want to
say anything right now
but um but i've seen every one of the
movies i love superhero
movies i love star wars i love all that
stuff black panther was a very average
movie there there was
in my opinion there was nothing racist
yes it was for shame
for shame racist well guess what larry
elder said it too
yeah but he's a self-hating black you
just can't win here but but my point is
that it was if within the scheme of
superhero movies yeah none of them get
nominated for anything yeah
and that's fine that it was very average
in my opinion it was just a very average
movie and it got nominated for all these
things and i saw the media it was like
ah see black panther got it like it was
some major win
yeah that that would somehow make people
more equal or feel
better or now we can look at the numbers
and go this many black films this and
this many white houses
and i was like it just seems to me that
the aim is just so
off yeah of where you should go for the
prize the real prize
no and i agree with you on that first of
all i love black panther i i really do
like i'm a huge fan
so i can't i thought it was perfectly
fine but you had an oscar
award-winning i think nominated i think
that you make a really good point
in minority communities and specifically
the two groups that i'm a part of blacks
and and
gay people we always look for
representation in the media
as some sort of barometer of progress
and that's a trap it's a huge
it's a big truck chinese people do it
yeah because they're focused on making
money
and when i tell and i'm all about it and
when i go give these lectures and i tell
people that
the biggest way for any group of people
to achieve any kind of power is is
financially
it is not through oscar nominations
and that stuff is great and it's amazing
but
it's it's it's kind of like these are
these are false idols
because black panther is is great for
visual representation and it's great
that all those people on the stage and i
personally think this amazing movie yeah
but what that does for
the young black kid that's struggling in
the high school that i went to right now
not much not much right yeah um and and
we do it as as gays and lesbians as well
if you know if somebody comes out and
look at the look at the the the buddha
judge thing right now
yeah yeah yeah look at how people and
this is somebody that is
i mean i'm not a buddhist hater at all
but
i it seems to me you know i see the game
i see what's going on
and i see the way that he picked the
fight with pence to to ingratiate
himself to the far left that there's
like i get it yeah i see it but just the
idea
that any power comes from media
representation
it's it's false hope and it also
separates the people from what should be
the end goal
because i think that empowerment for any
of our communities only comes through
entrepreneurship
look at this look that is your name on
that
sign you're an entrepreneur and if
somebody had given me the message about
entrepreneurship
when i was 17 18 19 20 god knows where
i'd be by now
and one of the biggest things that i've
gotten out of out of becoming
conservative and kind of moving over to
the right
is the fact that entrepreneurship and
capitalism is not a bad thing
and my both of our communities need more
of it but especially my black community
we need
more entrepreneurship we need more job
creators we need to stop
looking for representation in the media
to
to to elevate ourselves or to make us
feel good about ourselves
so when you see then the democrats so
just in the last couple weeks yeah
there's now this debate suddenly about
reparations
and i i saw the video of senator
elizabeth warren talking about
reparations and she's going to
commission a panel about reparations
and my first thought the first thing
that just popped into my head as i was
watching it
was holy [ __ ] candace did it
you know what i mean like whatever
anyone thinks of candace she
created enough of a crack
in that layer that that caused black
people to
either be completely afraid of saying
they're conservatives or just just say
that they're not democrats yeah yeah
that now the democrats are like oh [ __ ]
what do we got left here's money could
you take some money
yeah that's money in the words of the
great candace owens
fear and handouts is what they have to
offer black people the cycle and
it is no mistake first of all that
donald trump got more
african-american votes than the two
previous republican nominees combined
that is just a fact and it is no mistake
that
you know what you know people say a lot
about the blexit movement and they say
it's not real it's not that and what i
tell people
is that you're going to see republicans
make a bigger play for the black vote
than you have
ever seen before i think in the history
of this country
and it's not going to come through fear
and handouts it's going to come from
talking to the people that are the real
job creators and the real entrepreneurs
and saying that these policies will help
you create
and the fact that reparations is even a
conversation right now among the
democrats means that they're scared
um i i just did a a video for for
turning point about reparations and and
not to spoil any of that
but none other than bayern rustin
who is one of the architects of the
march on washington a huge civil rights
leader who by the way was black and gay
in the 60s
they interviewed baird rustin about
reparations in 1969
and he said it's he said this idea is
ridiculous
and the quote is something like if my
great-great-grandfather
you know picked cotton then reparations
are owed to him
but he's dead and nobody owes me
anything yeah but this is how they're
going to try to buy the black boat
it's also just a crazy way of dividing
us
yes each other i was at a cousin's
wedding on my husband's side this past
weekend
and was with a young guy
who's 21 22 and he was telling me about
how woke it is in college now
this is this is a kid who grew up his
mother died when he was very young he
grew up he had
no money bunch of different homes
all sorts of crazy history in the family
and it's like
the idea that this kid has privilege
because he's white and we're going to
take from him
i mean that's in essence that's what he
was saying to me like and it wasn't
specifically about reparations but just
this idea
that this kid is somehow guilty yeah or
somehow privileged
just because of the skin color having
nothing to do with everything he's lived
through but that's what they're pushing
on everybody
i mean you know that's what they're
pushing and and there's not a lot of
pushback to that idea
and i just feel that there's a
correction
going on right now and there's a
correction because you're seeing
a lot more conservatives that are
younger and browner and whatever and
there's a really different movement
right now
and the the leftist it's like i call it
the intersectionality cult
the intersectionality cult will eat
itself because there's all these things
that you cannot say on the left right
now and
there's somebody who who i'm not going
to name but this is this person
is it has a platform as a feminist right
and this is a male feminist and i'm like
great you know do what you got to do but
don't call me transphobic for defending
women's sports or women's spaces or or
lesbians who are now who now feel
pressured into having relationships with
transgender women
yeah um when when you call yourself a
feminist and you're not standing up for
for lesbians not standing up for women
in that way
i i you know you call me whatever you
want to call me but i'm always going to
to stand up for for lesbians to stand up
for women in that way
but like i said the intersectionality
code there are things that they can't
say
um there are things that they can't say
about radical islam
you know when when they run into a gay
bar and kill 49 of us
they can't say that you got jonathan
capehart running around
talking about oh this guy was a closeted
gay and this guy was this and this guy
was that and i'm like
that is completely ridiculous and not
true and we know that that's not true
now
but the intersectionality cult will eat
itself because they're
there it is becoming to the point where
there are too many things that they
can't say
so people like you and i have to say the
things that they can't say
is that doubly tough then for you as a
gay black man because
the culture if we're talking about black
culture and gay culture there's so much
humor richness there
political incorrectness yeah yeah all of
these things so for someone like you to
be
fed these these ideas you've obviously
rejected now
but to be fed these ideas that would
stop you from joking the way you want a
joke or saying something politically
incorrect
the rest of it it's like like i remember
go when i would go to gay bars and there
would be like a drag queen now i
i i again i was never into it i thought
drag queens
were all bad comics like they all struck
me as just hack comics
that being said they would say a ton of
politically
incorrect [ __ ] they would mock gay
people they i mean they would mock
everybody that was the point
yeah where now it's like i don't know i
don't know what's going on in the
drag queen world these days but it's
like i'm guessing it's gotten pretty bad
because they're probably really afraid
to say anything yeah to be irreverent i
mean i i think that right now i mean i
love drag i love rupaul's drag race like
i'm all about it you know my husband and
i are big fans
when i voted uh for the in the last
lecture voting for gary johnson but i
used to live in west hollywood so i had
to go over there to vote yeah i was
standing behind rupaul at the voters
wow not in drag and you want to talk
about like
and you want to talk about how crazy the
left is let's
talk about rupaul let's talk about the
crazy blue chest this is the point
crazies on the lgbt left
coming after rupaul like forgive me for
being gay
mother yeah as they would say you come
from mother
and you you say that rupaul is
transphobic or she doesn't represent
gays or whatever what what was it that
she said
it was okay this is about a year and a
half ago this is about a year and a half
ago like
um rupaul did an interview where she
said she doesn't
we're paul he because rupaul's a man
rupaul said he doesn't believe
in in transgender women and drag because
drag is supposed to be a male's elevated
and comedic idea of what
a woman is and so they came after rupaul
for that
they came after there was a um a segment
on drag race called uh she she may oh
girl you got she
know you know what i mean and so they
kid the blue checks came after rupaul
for that
and so it's really funny when i look at
the rupaul situation
and we'll look at somebody who has done
more
for for lgbt culture than maybe anybody
walking on this earth right now
and the fact that people are attacking
him
after everything that he's done tells me
that these people are insane
tells me that there's not enough and and
if there's one thing
that that i wouldn't you i don't know if
this is a critique because i i
love rupaul and by all accounts i hear
people say that rue is amazing
it's that like rue kind of ben bended
the knee a little bit oh no
he apologizes bended the knee a little
bit um um
to people coming for him and i want to
get to a point where we are not bending
the knee to the mob anymore
yeah they came after ellen degeneres
what lesbian
on this planet has done more for
freaking
gay and lesbian visibility than ellen
degeneres you know it came after ellen
just because she sat down with uh kevin
kevin having the conversation with kevyn
hart and they came for ellen
and so this is what i say if they're
coming for
rupaul and ellen degeneres they'll come
for you and me
so die so i will never bend the knee i
was um
we were supposed to have an lgbt
conservative panel
at the lgbt center in new york city um
and when you know people found out about
it we got excommunicated from the center
because we were all racist and all white
and transphobic and all of that other
stuff
and so i will never apologize for things
that i
say i don't try to offend people but
you're certainly not going to control my
tongue
and i'm not going to bend the knee to
these people and i'm really glad that
ellen didn't
and i hope rupaul never does again
because these are two people that have
done more for this community than
anybody on the planet
certainly not some blue check mark that
writes for some blog
right right right but we create this
reverse or this perverse i should say
incentive structure
where it's like there's a lot of value
for those blue checkers to go after them
because it's like
oh you can wound one of the heroes even
if they were the ones that paved the
road for you yeah wow if you can build
your castle on their blood yeah
you know cardi b says they do anything
for clout
club chasers that's all they're doing
and
the the fundamental critique that i have
with with a lot of these people
the the clout chasers is that the
platforms are always built on
destruction
it's cancel culture so everything is
always built on
if i build a platform of let's say like
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
three hundred thousand
and my platform is completely built on
tearing people down
like i'm gonna go after dave rubin
because he's got ten times my following
and he said something i don't like
so maybe i'll get some attention for
tearing him down yeah you know what i
mean
so if your platform is built on that
then you
always have to look for new things to be
offended by
new people to destroy new cloud to chase
and i don't think that it goes anywhere
yeah you know
well it's also sad right it's like it's
deeply i mean i see this with
this crew going after me all the time
and i just ignore it but it's like
the idea that you're waking up in the
morning and going what did ruben say
today so i can get some clicks it's like
man there's so many things going on in
the world
yeah and it's like i'm not perfect and
i've made mistakes in this very room
yeah this show but it's like if you're
waking up going this is the guy we got
to go after
i i says more about you than it says
about me it does and and i feel sorry
i just i i feel sorry for their life
because i just
there's nowhere to go from that and i
would like to use
these opportunities that i'm getting
right now to
i want to engage people but i also want
to empower people like i want to empower
my people
as much crap as as candace owens gets
and man she gets the
a level that i can even dream of
she is a true believer she is
really out here trying to empower people
she is really out here trying to wake
people up
and i i um i saw brene brown
special i think her name is renee brown
on on netflix so she's
apparently enormously huge motivational
speaker who i've never heard of
um so she just got um promoted to me on
netflix so i decided to watch a little
bit of the um special
and she said that and i think she i
think this is a theodore roosevelt quote
she said that don't worry about
critiques
that come from people who are not in the
field who are not in the battle who are
not putting themselves out there in some
way
and trying to affect change in some way
and
now that i've saw i've seen that that's
how i try to live my life
and because you can't take all these
critiques there's a point where
you can get ninety percent of love from
people and we'll focus on the ten
percent of eight yeah yeah
but i was really doing stand up i always
remember i could be killing like 300
people laughing especially
if there's one guy looking at his phone
it's like that's the guy i'm looking at
yeah
what are you doing there's a guy that
was asleep in my lecture last night
did you call him out i did i said i
didn't call him out directly
but i was like give my speech and i was
like you know and and i think that
everybody needs to have conversations
even that guy
that's funny did he wake up he did he
did that's good
i'm sorry we didn't do more of this
earlier but tell me a little bit just
about your service having nothing to do
with
with all that yeah just you know my
service in general i think that
when i look back at the military service
what i regret
is that you know people come up to you
when you're a veteran
and they thank you for your service and
like people call me a hero
and all that other stuff and i'm always
uneasy by that
because i didn't do anything
particularly heroic
i i was a young kid um just just trying
to make it from one day to
the next i mean i was doing things that
i believed in but
when i look at some of these kids that
are serving right now and they're the
same age i was you know 19 20 21 years
old
it's so much for a young person to take
on
but for me when i look back at it and it
just it
you know i lost weight and it gave me
discipline and it gave me kind of
that that strong male influence that was
missing in my life
and when i talk about my service it's
not so much the day-to-day of what i did
because
it was really you know i did uh one tour
in kuwait i did one tour in a rock right
after the invasion
um you connect those dots you can get to
that age question that you had
okay now i can put this all together
yeah connect the dots it's okay yeah
yeah um
but when i look back to that we were
just i was just trying to do the best
that i could
and everybody that i served with we were
just trying to do our best
and the people that are serving the
military they are heroes
from like from the guy who captured
osama bin laden and indies these great
men that you see these books from and
all that stuff
but just the people that that give up
three
four five sometimes 20 and 25 years of
their life to be of service
in some way like there is a very heroic
element to that
and i think that with me and my service
i talk about it a lot and
i talk about loving america because it
has given me so much
just that service has just put me onto a
path that
just sitting here with you right now and
coming back from being with candace and
going to events in the white house like
what what poor black kid from akron ohio
could could see that vision for himself
and the military put me on the path to
doing all of these things
so i don't look at myself as heroic but
i look at all the people that are
serving now as heroic it's to me it's
it's very strange i feel like i'm not
giving you an answer but no no
it's very hard to reconcile who i am now
with who i was then
and to see that as anything other than a
scared kid doing the best he could
if that makes sense it does make sense
yeah and that feels like a nice ending
yeah
how do you feel about that i think
that's a great ending there you go
i don't know what i'm doing later but
there would be something if we just
showed up at the abbey in west hollywood
oh my god
the two of us could we find some other
banded deplorable oh my god
we should we should make it happen we
should we should make the the
conservative gay meet up or something
like that we should make it happen
classical liberal oh that's right
classical liberal come on
for more on rob follow him on twitter at
rob smith online
[Music]
you